[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with a former conservative minister and
broadcaster anna subri and the pr
consultant alex dean so let's see what's
on some of those front pages for you now
it's not too much to mask is the
headline on the front of the metro as
mars are set to become mandatory again
in shops and on public transport in
england
meanwhile the telegraph warns new
requirements for everyone including
children to isolate if they come into
contact with omicron
cases will cause chaos in schools
the guardian says that the new
restrictions are likely to come with a
widening of the booster jab program to
stem the spread of the virus
and the time says every adult is to get
a booster jab to try to save christmas
that's also the lead in the daily mail
the mirror takes a similar line with the
fight to save christmas
the financial times leads on the flurry
of new global travel restrictions
introduced amidst concerns over omicron
despite opposition from the world health
organization
and the son says prince charles has
called in lawyers over claims in a new
book that he is racist
and we are joined tonight by ana subri
and alex dean welcome
to you both um let's kick off with the
metro uh their headline it's not too
much to mask these are the the new
restrictions that are being brought in
to where uh mars on public transport and
in uh shops etc alex
yeah the prime minister announced this
many people will have seen uh at five
o'clock on friday it seems to me this is
a peculiar one not least because it
doesn't apply to bars and restaurants uh
nor should it i think but given that
you're gonna be eating and drinking but
given there are so many mixed venues and
places where people both eat drink and
shop shopping malls and centers that
have both restaurants and bars and shops
and so forth i think this one's going to
be rather difficult to enforce moreover
it does seem funny to me because the
same people who are now telling us to
wear masks the same scientists are the
people who told us a year ago two years
ago that wearing masks had little to no
uh difference to um the spread of
vaccine the spread of viruses and that
we wouldn't need to wear masks and
people suggesting we should have got it
wrong
since then alex so we've learned a lot a
lot more about the virus and it wasn't
known at that time
no no what's happened has been good
because we've been vaccinated and we
were told that being vaccinated was
going to be the way out of this
situation not the way into a whole new
world of bureaucratic rules and more
mask wearing
anna
look i'm sorry what's the problem with
wearing a mask
if you're asking me the answer is that
it's dehumanized and unpleasant
well
look we either are serious about this or
we're not and i listened to a scientist
none of us just a man alex none of us
particularly like wearing a mark but we
wear a mask because the scientific
advice is that it helps stop the spread
and that's all that matters at the
moment it's about protecting the nhs and
saving lives and i am absolute i don't
understand people who put belts on when
they get into their car quite properly
if you ride a motorbike or a scooter put
a helmet on sensible measures to protect
yourself what is wrong in the middle of
a pandemic with wearing a mask
to some sort of status thing to show how
either right wing or manly you are
i don't think it's to do with neither my
manliness nor my right wingness i was
trying to make a point about the fact
that you the rhetoric that you've just
used about protecting the nhs and uh
three weeks to flatten the curve and so
forth that worked 18 months ago it
worked even a year ago i think now
broadly speaking it doesn't convince
people and the fact you feel we need to
say it more aggressively and personally
perhaps underlines the fact that it's
less convincing than it was because
you've still not explained what is wrong
with wearing a mask to which you would
say well it's bureaucratic
no no i said it it's completely lost on
me
if somebody tells me to wear three masks
to keep this infection at bay i'll wear
three masks but alex you're saying
alex you're saying that it's
dehumanizing um but if it could
potentially save lives isn't it worth
the the effort
my point is there's going to come a time
when this this rhetoric if you know if
it saves one life it's all worth it it's
going to erode itself into nothingness
this precautionary principle will have
us in the end locked down in our own
homes wearing masks and so forth for the
rest of our lives we're going to have to
it's going to have to come a point at
which we accept there's a certain amount
of risk we accept in life otherwise well
i don't know what anna's expecting this
but if you say you're going to wear
three masks forever i mean there has to
come a point when we accept there's a
certain amount of risk we put up with in
life
we're not talking about risk we're
talking about
saving lives and protecting our nhs and
that's not empty rhetoric that's reality
and if wearing a mask reduces the
infection rate i don't see what the
problem is let's move on to the mirror
and they're saying the fight to save
christmas presumably alex um
you believe that it's not appropriate to
wear masks in social settings like like
restaurants etc which are exempt from
the new restrictions
yeah i mean the government hasn't said
that so and let's let's say it doesn't i
mean christmas on the one hand will of
course feel like an arbitrary time and
it has different meanings for different
people but i will point out this feels
eerily like last year when we had a
conversation about saving christmas and
it'll all be okay by christmas the
trouble with setting deadlines like this
is that when you miss them people tend
to remember and then when you set the
same deadline again a year later they
certainly remember it are we going to be
saying let's have the fight to say
christmas in three weeks to flatten the
curve in 2024 2025 because it seems to
me that anna's logic means we would
anna do you think that we should be
wearing master in in restaurants
well i think that there's a good
argument for it but i would be always
guided by the science look i think the
real problem about masks is
notwithstanding that we have a prime
minister who has a problem in wearing a
mask and too many conservative mps who
seem to have a problem with wearing
masks but also if you go into a lot of
shops if you go into other public places
you're getting mixed messages from a lot
of the staff because they're not what
they're wearing masks either so one of
the things i would say is we need
clarity i mean i don't always wear a
mask so i forget to take it with me if
you go into a shop you go into a place
and the person people working there
aren't wearing them you kind of think oh
well there's no point so i we need
clarity that's the thing about good
public health messaging it needs to be
good and clear but you know this i mean
i'm not getting i don't get this thing
about you know we've got a saved
christmas and all the rest of it what we
have got to do is make sure and it's not
empty rhetoric we need to make sure that
we stop the spread of the virus in a way
that damages our nhs and it causes more
people to die and at the moment we have
this new variant we don't know a lot
about it so let's be guided by the
scientists who certainly know more i put
my hands up than i know and i don't have
a problem in following their guidance
but this idea that we're going to be
locked up in our homes until 2025 and
all the rest of it
i think that's that's a gross
exaggeration as i say what we need is
good clear
leadership we need good clear public
health messages we need to listen to the
advice of the
experts in this the people that know far
more than we do
meanwhile alex the telegraph tells us
that the omicron variant will lead to
chaos in schools because potentially
children will be um required to to
self-isolate if coming into contact with
those who who might have been exposed to
omicron
absolutely and think of the difficulties
the challenges and the unhappiness that
has been caused in many young lives by
the precautions and measures that we've
taken coronavirus already two years of
education uh have been somewhere between
stymied and wrecked for young people in
this country as we've tried to do
what ana has rightly set out and tried
to lessen the effect of the virus the
notion now that people should be forced
into isolation if they may have come
into contact with somebody because of
this new variant seems to me that the
telegraph is right it's going to cause
chaos in schools and you know what my
fear is there's always going to be a new
variant are we saying that we're going
to disrupt education forever and a day
now because of this
the implications are that thousands of
healthy children might have to to stay
at home anna but is there
any other way around this
i think that's the problem
what is the alternative look we don't
know enough yet about omnicom so we
we can't overly speculate obviously
people are nervous and worried but i
absolutely agree with alex the impact
that this this awful 18 months two years
almost has had on many people's lives
especially young people's lives has been
has been terrible for them and two years
of disruption to their education the
effects on mental health and so on and
so forth but time and again we come back
to well what is the alternative and the
alternative is not just to let viruses
rip because we know that it's not just
that people die it's also that it has
this huge impact as it's already had on
our nhs which then affects all our lives
but i do care about people dying and i
do care about the impact on the nhs as
much as i care about the impact on
youngsters so it's all about balance and
trying to get the right balance keeping
the virus in check keeping people safe
as much as we possibly can